un adil et ghazi karoui libéré par la
justice algérienne n'est pas blanchi et
l'ex candidat à la présidentielle
tunisienne de 2019 et son frère ont
quitté la prison de constantine et
demeurent à la disposition de la justice
algérienne a' les deux frères sont
poursuivis pour être entré illégalement
en algérie en fait le point avec notre
correspondant à tunis bassam 6 ils
auront passé moins de deux mois derrière
les barreaux de la prison de boussouf
dans l'est algérien nabil karoui
président du parti reparle toulouse
deuxième formation politique du pays et
son frère le député ghazi karoui ont été
libérés par la justice algérienne après
avoir été accusés d'être entrés en
algérie de manière illégale
l'information a été révélée lundi soir
par le quotidien algérien arrive ça qui
précise que les deux frères kaori devons
rester à la disposition de la justice
algérienne jusqu'à clôture de
l'instruction son obligation de demeurer
une sur le sol algérien une libération
qui intervient après une énième demande
déposée par leur avocat auprès du
procureur de constantine et après qu'ils
aient apporté toutes les garanties d'une
liberté conditionnelle
une libération qui n'annule en aucun cas
les poursuites retenu contre les deux
frères présenté début septembre devant
le juge d'instruction près le tribunal
de tébessa il avait été placé sous
mandat de dépôt avec quatre autres
complices tous d'origine algérienne et
les frères karoui avait fui la tunisie
quelques jours après le coup de force du
président sayed et le déploiement
consécutive une opération mains propres
contre de nombreux hommes d'affaires et
personnalités politiques soupçonnés de
corruption par le palais de carthage en
tunisie et les deux frères sont toujours
poursuivis en outre pour évasion fiscale
et blanchiment d'argent